so we're going to discuss today when
victimhood counts as the fallout from
parkland continues plus stormy Daniels
befuddled as the White House and Paul
Ryan is he on his way out
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
oh man so many things to get to today
and we will get to all of them first I
want to say thank you hover to our
sponsors over at bull and branch so
you've not been getting enough sleep and
you think that you've not been getting
enough sleep because you're stressed or
because you're not exercising one of the
reasons you're not getting enough sleep
is because your sheets stink okay you
know you they do you just stopped at the
side of the road there's some weird guy
who was selling thousand thread count
sheets and you picked them up and you've
been sleeping on it and you've been
sleeping on a plastic tarp ever since
well bull and branch can fix that for
you okay bull and branch makes the best
bedding and the best blankets made from
pure 100% organic cotton which means
they start out super soft they get even
softer over time and you can buy
directly from them so you're essentially
playing wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a thousand dollars in the
store well and Brad she told me a couple
of hundred bucks and that's well worth
it since you're sleeping on them every
night everyone who tries bull and branch
sheets loves them in fact we threw out
all of our other sheets and bought only
bull and branch after we started working
with them that's why they have thousands
of five-star reviews it's why Forbes The
Wall Street Journal Fast Company they're
all talking about bull and branch even
three US presidents and Bill Clinton's
ex-lovers sleep unbolt and branch sheets
shipping is free can try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund
but you're not gonna want to send them
back they really are that good to get
you started right now my listeners get
$50 off your first set of sheets at bull
and branch calm promo code Ben that's
bull and branch comp remote command for
50 bucks off your first set of sheets
again all of their sheets are just
phenomenal and their other products are
as well you sleep much better in your
own bed when you have a great pair of
sheets that's a bull and branch does for
you bol el and branch com use that promo
club and get 50 bucks off and let them
know that we sent you alright so we've
been hearing for weeks that those of us
who are in favor of second Amendment
rights are somehow weird crazy right
because we're all worried that they're
gonna take our guns and what you'll hear
from people and left is no we don't want
to take your guns no we're not
interested in in taking your doesn't to
take your guns under it he said no no
and then of course they argue that they
want to take our guns the latest example
of this comes courtesy a former Supreme
Court Justice John Paul Stevens said
John Paul Stevens was appointed by
Republicans and then he proceeded to
govern left of Ruth Bader Ginsburg that
is not a joke if you actually look
people have charted how particular
justices govern and rule from the bench
John Paul Stevens is one of the most
liberal members of the court for nearly
his entire tenure he was one of the
worst picks I believe he was appointed
by President Reagan Warren
worst pics of President Reagan and he
has just been disastrous in fact you
know I'm gonna check that real fact with
you that he was appointed by he may have
been appointed by Nixon yeah he's
pointed by by President Nixon rap oh
sorry
Gerald Ford he's appointed by Gerald
Ford but he was one of Gerald Ford's
worst moves and now he has an op-ed in
the New York Times literally titled to
repeal the Second Amendment which makes
the second top ad in the New York Times
in the last two years calling for full
repeal of the Second Amendment after
Brett Stevens wrote the same thing and
Brett is their in-house conservative
over there so John Paul Stevens writes
this full op-ed about why we should get
rid of the Second Amendment entirely
first of all completely unrealistic in
order to pass a constitutional amendment
you require two-thirds approval of each
house of Congress plus three-quarters of
all state legislatures look at a map
it's all read if there are 30-some
governors in the United States who are
Republican zero state legislatures are
actually gonna pass this thing outside
of California Massachusetts New York and
maybe you know Minnesota or something
and then the notion that a bunch of
people are sitting around waiting to
repeal the Second Amendment is just not
accurate but let's go through John Paul
Stevens is awful argument in the New
York Times for why they were a Second
Amendment should be repealed so he
begins by praising the marches and
rallies that have been taking place
since the Parkland shooting he writes
this rarely in my lifetime have I seen
the type of civic engagement
schoolchildren and their supporters
demonstrated in Washington and other
major cities throughout the country this
past Saturday these demonstrations
demand our respect they revealed the
broad public support for legislation to
minimize the risk of mass killings of
schoolchildren and others in our society
so number one this is stupid
this is incredibly stupid Haley the if
you really believe that big rallies mean
that there's tremendous support for
hardcore gay anti-gun legislation then
you've never seen a rally before if
first of all was rally within that bag
there are 200,000 people who showed up
in DC sizeable rally sure
hey in 2000 there's the million mom
March also for gun control also anti NRA
and three-quarters of a million people
showed up in Washington DC at that point
I believe Bill Clinton was still
president technically and nothing
happened
zero things happen there is it and
there's been serious seriously pretty
much zero gun legislation between two
thousand and two thousand eighteen
despite multiple major rallies on gun
control and it's worth noting that when
tea partiers were out there by the
hundreds of thousands nobody seems to
care about that either every year the
March for life happens in several
hundred
thousand people and pro-life legislation
does not inevitably follow nor would
people on the left suggest Wow look at
the public support for that
that means we suddenly have to get rid
of abortion rights so this is really
dumb and then he continues he says the
marches are a sign that it's time to
seriously curb weapons ownership quote
that support is a clear sign to
lawmakers to enact legislation
prohibiting civilian ownership of
semi-automatic weapons increasing the
minimum age to buy a gun from 18 to 21
and establishing more comprehensive
background checks on all purchasers of
firearms but the demonstrator should
seek more effective and more lasting
reform they should demand a repeal of
the Second Amendment so it's not enough
to pass a law that would bar civilian
ownership of semi-automatic weapons
which is to say virtually every weapon
in the United States again for those who
don't know anything about guns a
semi-automatic weapon just means you
pull the trigger once and one bullet
fires and another one is loaded into the
chamber that is all a semi-automatic
weapon is that's the only thing that
distinguishes between a revolver and a
semi-automatic weapon is that there is a
is there is a changing cylinder in a
revolver that doesn't exist in a
semi-automatic weapon
virtually every weapon in the United
States unless it is boat loading muzzle
loading or a revolver is a
semi-automatic weapon virtually all of
them and there are 300 million of them
in the United States so he said well my
problem just covered a semi-automatic
weapons everything will be fine yeah
yeah good luck with that one okay but
then he says that he wants the Second
Amendment gone so it's not enough to
just get rid of it and then I love this
that the left keeps saying that we're
just idly worried about second Amendment
rights being violated we're not we can
have common-sense gun regulations yeah
at least even's is being honest at least
he's being honest so he says let's get
rid of the Second Amendment entirely he
says quote concerned that a national
standing army might pose a threat to the
security of the separate states led to
the adoption of that amendment which
provides the quote a well-regulated
militia being necessary to the security
of a free State the right of the people
to keep and bear Arms shall not be
infringed today that concern is a relic
of the 18th century well no no it isn't
ok the concern that the federal
government would invade our rights and
in really egregious manner and that we
might need guns to protect ourselves I'm
wondering how that a relic of the 18th
century when we have had beyond the 18th
century full-on slavery in the United
States Jim Crow removal of gun rights
from black folks removal of gun rights
from from a wide variety of people
including japanese-americans during
world war ii and the forcible
imprisonment of Japanese during the
World War two it seems to me that in
armed papa
raishin is a better guarantee than
sitting around thinking that the
government will never go to radical it
just is that's not to suggest that every
armed rebellion is good or that it will
end well or that armed rebellions are
largely successful but one of the
reasons that the government doesn't go
for tyrannical is because they know that
there are 100 million people in the
United States who own guns try telling a
bunch of Texans they are not violating
their rights when you say you want to go
into their basements and take out all of
their guns again good luck with that
this is not this concern is it you know
historically ignorant you have to be to
believe that it's a relic of the 18th
century to worry about centralized
government taking your guns and then
invading your rights it's happened in
virtually every tyrannical country it's
happened in China it has happened in the
Soviet Union it's happened in Nazi
Germany the sort of stuff happens all
the time routinely
a lot so then he continued says for over
200 years after the adoption of the
Second Amendment it was uniformly
understood as not placing any limit on
either federal or state authority to
enact gun control legislation in 1939
the Supreme Court unanimously held that
Congress could prohibit the possession
of a sawed-off shotgun because that
weapon had no reasonable relation to the
preservation or efficiency of a
quote/unquote well-regulated militia
well that's not even a real reading of
the case that's a bad reading of the
case if the idea here is that you have
to be a member of the militia in order
to carry a gun that is absolutely untrue
it is not true at the time of the
founding it is not true throughout
American history it's not even true in
the case that Stephens is citing stevens
was a bad Supreme Court justice and he's
an ignoramus when it comes to actual
jurisprudence ok the case he's citing
his United States versus Miller in 1939
Justice Scalia explained this case to
Stephens in his opinion in DC versus in
Heller versus DC he said quote Miller
did not hold that and cannot be possibly
read to have held that quote the
judgments in the case upheld against a
Second Amendment challenge to men's
federal convictions for transporting an
unregistered short barreled shotgun in
interstate commerce in violation of the
National Firearms Act it is entirely
clear that the courts basis for saying
the Second Amendment did not apply was
not that the defendants were bearing
arms not for military purposes rather it
was the type of weapon at issue was not
eligible for the Second Amendment
protection this whole thing is consists
not only consistent with but positively
suggests that the Second Amendment
confers an individual right to keep and
bear arms the only arms that have some
reasonable relationship to the
preservation or efficiency of a railroad
well-regulated militia and the court
believed that the
Second Amendment protects only those
serving in the militia it would have
been odd to examine the character of the
weapon rather than simply note that the
true two crooks were not militiamen
furthermore this has been understood for
literally hundreds of years one of the
reasons in the Dred Scott decision the
evil horrible Dred Scott decision in
which the Supreme Court decided that
black people in America could not be
full citizens of the United States
hey justice Tony wrote in that decision
that one of the reasons black people
could not be citizens of the United
States is that if you made them citizens
of the United States then they'd be able
to carry guns the obvious underlying
assumption being that citizens of the
United States have the ability to carry
guns that they have the right to carry
guns under the Constitution of the
United States and here's what justice
Tony wrote in that evil Dred Scott
decision quote it would give to persons
of the Negro race who are recognized as
citizens in any one state of the Union
the right to enter every other state
whenever they please it would give them
full liberty of speech in public and in
private upon all subjects upon which
citizens might speak to hold public
meetings upon political affairs and to
keep and carry arms wherever they went
and the scared Justice xx this is why he
said that we wouldn't allow black people
to be citizens and that they had to
remain sort of property and this evil
decision he said because if you were to
make them citizens then there are rights
that comes along with being a citizen
one of those rights is carrying firearms
but Stevens isn't done then he quotes
Chief Justice Warren burger
who's the man responsible for such
constitutional abominations as Roe
versus Wade and he says that chief
Warren burger used to say that the NRA
was stupid well who cares the chief
Lorne burger had to say that guy was a
terrible Justice Warren burger was such
a bad justice the Potter Stewart another
justice on the Supreme Court leach
dramatically to Woodward and Bernstein
his Karl Woodward was a Bernstein
Woodward it was to one of them I in
their book the Brethren okay the
Brethren is a book about the inside
workings of the Supreme Court Potter
Stewart hated Warren burger so much that
he leaked the entire book okay to to
Woodward and Bernstein about why Warren
burger was an idiot everybody on the
court thought Warren burger was an idiot
except for John Paul Stevens apparently
okay so in any case he then rips into
District of Columbia vs. Heller that's
DC vs. Heller the 2008 case that Rhian
shrined the American right to keep him
bare and keeping bear arms and here's
what Stevens concludes he says that
decision which I remain convinced was
wrong and certainly was debatable has
provided the NRA with a propaganda
weapon of immense power well actually
they had a second amendment before that
overturning that decision via a
constitutional amendment to get rid of
Second Amendment would be simple it
would do more to weaken the NRA's
ability to stymie legislative debate and
block constructive gun control
legislation than any other available
option okay so it would be easy to get
rid of the Second Amendment go ahead and
try left us please do it make this your
rally and cry please tell Republicans
all over the country they're gonna take
away their weapons and repeal the Second
Amendment do it I dare you you want to
see yourselves get killed in November
politically speaking you want to see it
just construed politically speaking do
this push for a giant gun control effort
okay in just a second I'm going to talk
about another idiotic rant on gun
control but first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at the u.s. CCA hey
as you may have noticed your gun rights
are in fact under attack the folks on
the Left are interested in taking away
your gun rights and that's why we are
working very hard to ensure that people
who have guns know what to do with them
not just for resistance to government
but also because as a law-abiding gun
owner you have a right to keep and bear
arms hey you are running out of time to
claim your free mass shooting Survival
Guide an audio book if you're listening
right now you know we live in dangerous
times but enough is enough when it comes
to protecting the people you love you
deserve to know the truth you're about
to miss your free copy of the complete
mass shooting Survival Guide from the US
CCA go to defend my family now calm
while you still can its defend my family
now calm it's 100% free in this book you
will learn what we really need to know
about mass shootings how does it arrive
an attack proven strategies for stopping
a shooter and a whole lot more again
well left fulminates about guns
generally make sure that you know how to
protect yourself that's what this guide
is for plus you can claim your copy in
seconds to 100% free and if you act now
you also get a bonus security checklist
to print off your local school church or
office don't miss this life-saving guide
an audiobook you're 100% free copies
will be gone next week go to defend my
family now calm to claim yours well
their lat while they last again its
defend my family now calm defend my
family now calm ensure that you and your
family are protected in case of god
forbid a mass shooting make sure that
you know what to do this is why the OCC
is helping you out in a way the lefties
are okay the folks on the left are
saying give up your gun and we'll keep
you safe the occa is saying keep
yourself safe and know how to do it get
your free copy of the complete mass
shooting Survival Guide from the US CCI
defend my family now calm that's defend
my family now calm okay I wasn't the
only dumb notion that was being pushed
by the left today from John Paul Stevens
there is also a tweet storm from Michael
Ian Black who's a comedian
and that means that he must know lots
about guns right because he's a comedian
so that means that he knows a lot about
guns so here's his Tweed storm he says
quote I'll say it assault weapons aren't
the problem
handguns are the problem by all means be
ar-15s and the like but handguns kill
far more people the solution is to
repeal and replace the Second Amendment
make gun ownership a privilege not right
okay at least they're being honest now
at least Michael Ian Black and John Paul
Stevens they're being honest now and
they will be increasingly honest as time
goes on I'm old enough to remember when
the Democrats claimed they weren't for
nationalized health care and now of
course this has become a thing they like
to do is nationalize health care and
Michael Ian Black continues along these
lines
he says thirty-eight thousand Americans
died from gun violence last year what
number would you like to compromise to
twenty thousand well no I'd like that
number to be zero but let's recognize
the thirty eight thousand Americans
didn't I have gun violence two-thirds of
those died of suicide and among the
others were a various number of
criminals and then he continues along
these lines as well cutlery doesn't
cause obesity's but guns do caused gun
deaths well that's idiotic
guns do not cause gun deaths that's like
saying guns cause death no the person
who pulls the trigger cause death the
person who uses the cutlery is what
makes them fat so actually this is just
dumb and the stupidity continues is it
long round yes having the ready ability
to take someone's life is dominion over
that person gun ownership could be
viewed as slavery by another name
so me owning a gun and protecting myself
is slavery so I'm glad to know that
Michael Ian Black is a complete
historical ignoramus as you may have
heard just a few moments ago the Dred
Scott decision was fearful that black
people would have guns in fact gun
control legislation in the South was
specifically designed for literally a
hundred years to prevent black people
from being able to protect themselves
listen to Condoleezza Rice talk about
her dad having a gun and how he helped
protect her family with that gun if you
really believe the gun ownership is
slavery you have no knowledge of history
contemporary politics or gun ownership I
mean this is just inane it's just inane
gun ownership due to slavery I'll tell
you what slavery but slavery is me
giving up my gun to a government that
says it will protect me then they let me
die in a hail of bullets when a criminal
just decides not to obey the law but
he's not done yet
Michael Ian Black continues how's it
working out for people of color now
somebody points out to him that black
people have not been able to get guns
historically that's been bad for them he
says how's it working out for people of
color now well considering the black
people are largely shooting black people
and white people are largely shooting
white people it's hard to imagine that
people of color one
their gun rights removed law-abiding
people of color want their gun rights
removed
that's a weird argument so again all
these arguments are sort of weird and
then he he finally continues and he says
yes evidence supports the fact that easy
access to guns increases suicide
attempts and successful suicides in fact
the evidence is mixed on that the
Japanese suicide rate has remained
intensely high despite the fact that
very few guns in the country again none
of this has any relationship to reality
but doesn't matter folks on the Left
they're firmly convinced it's time to
get rid of the Second Amendment and we
thank them for their honesty because now
we can have a real debate a real
conversation it's all I asked for from
Piers Morgan years ago just tell me the
truth about what you want and then guess
what guess what we can have a
conversation and we can decide whether
Americans are really ready to surrender
their right to self-defense and the
right to keep and bear arms to a
government that fails to protect them on
a regular basis okay so meanwhile a lot
of hubbub has broken out about
quote-unquote attacks on the students of
parkland no one's attacking the students
of parkland we're attacking their
arguments they have a right to speak out
we all feel terrible for them obviously
witnesses to a shooting have gone
through something traumatic and horrible
it does not make them experts on gun
control we're all making the same
argument here and it's amazing to see
which survivors of gun violence are
actually put in the media and how the
media plays this stuff up so I do love
this morning Joe did another one of
their ubiquitous montages this montage
had to do with the March for March for
our lives on Saturday and they played
joe scarborough's protest song over it
so here's what that montage sounded like
[Music]
and they're showing all of these marches
about Vietnam and now they're trying
this montage Iraq and there's a Tim been
square they showed this yesterday
hey the march against poverty and now
there it is
the March for our lives okay so they
basically just recut this montage in
order to include the March for our lives
okay then the real reason for this of
course the the real reason that they
decide to show this montage is they can
push joe scarborough's crappy song love
it in the only way that you know
scarborough can sell his song is to do
montages on Morning Joe where they play
a song like nobody's buying the song
apparently so it's like if every time I
played something sad on the show I
played myself playing Schindler's List
hey Joe Scarborough has to play it's
just amazing every time there's a
protest now he's gonna find like three
guys standing outside of McDonald's
protesting for a raise and suddenly Joe
Scarborough is gonna show up with his
guitar and start playing it's gonna be
amazing I just I love it I love it it's
so it's so self-serving and so
self-aggrandizing it's incredible okay
but speaking of the students who must
never ever be their arguments must never
be attacked again it's amazing which
victims we choose to focus on so the
Eagles of Death Metal frontman went
after the students he said that these
parkland students are acting
inappropriately he is of course exactly
right and and here is what he had to say
he he unleashed a torrent of criticism
they put up a bunch of posts and in some
of the posts he said that some of the
student marshals were quote-unquote
pathetic and disgusting for playing
hooky at the expense of 16 of her
classmates blood and then he shared this
image of Emma Gonzales ripping up the US
Constitution now what's funny about that
is I don't know if you've seen this
going around but there is an image it's
a Jif that's been photoshopped of Emma
Gonzales tearing up a copy of the US
Constitution anybody who watches it
knows that this is obviously a Jif that
is meant to be symbolic that Emma
Gonzales doesn't like to guess
Constitution and therefore she's ripping
it up if you believe that chip was real
or that picture was real then you're an
idiot but the media is playing it like
the entire right believes that picture
is real that of course is not true
anyway he says quote as the survivor of
a mass shooting I can tell you from
firsthand experience that all of you
protesting and did taking days off from
school insult the memories of those who
were killed and abuse and insult me and
every other
of liberty by your every action may
every one of these disgusting vile
abusers of the Dead live as long as
possible so they can have the maximum
amount of time to enjoy their shame and
be cursed like a some pretty harsh
language I wouldn't use it but does he
have unquestioned moral authority Jesse
Hughes he's the bandleader of Eagles of
Death Metal who was of course at the
bottle on when that place was shot up
right it was his concert that was
attacked
does he have unquestioned moral
authority is he allowed to question
other survivors or there's only certain
survivors that we give on question moral
authorities and then and then I do like
this he tweeted out a graphic this is
pills that are hard to swallow our guns
aren't going anywhere there are only two
genders and Donald Trump will be a
president for you yeah it's a little bit
fun yeah well I will admit and again are
we allowed to question the arguments of
students because some of the argument
are really dumb so here's one parklands
student who is saying that
who's on on with brian Stelter and
inadvertently saying something really
true and really profound about the state
of journalism in our country i think
that for me the purpose of journalism is
to raise you know the voices of people
that maybe don't have a voice and so I
think that in its own right journalism
is a form of activism okay so a lot of
people on the Left we're saying for what
we're trying to distance themselves from
this comment that journalism is a form
of activism it is pretty obvious in the
wake of these shootings that journalism
is indeed a form of activism I've been
saying this for a very long time it's
why I call myself an opinion journalist
I'm honest about it folks at CNN are not
honest about it and they claim that
their objective news journalists in
reality they do have an agenda they are
pushing that agenda they are pushing
that agenda day in and day out
no wonder the student journalist
believes that journalism is activism she
watches CNN of course she believes
journalism is activism if I watch CNN on
a regular basis I believe that to a
journalism for CNN is indeed activism
this is how journalists see themselves
in fact I remember I visited the ABC
News offices with the god-king of The
Daily wire Jeremy boring and one of the
things that's head on the wall was
something to the effect of we give voice
to the voiceless and I just thought to
myself that's not journalism journalism
isn't about giving voice to the
voiceless it's about objectively
covering facts but people in the
journalistic business believe that it is
their job to actually push a particular
political agenda they believe that they
are do-gooders in the world not just
people covering the news and informing
folks this girl has obviously imbibed
from that and she's just spitting back
what what she's heard from the media
unfortunately she told the truth a
little bit too honestly right there for
the media to handle okay so in just a
second we will get to stormy Daniels
fall
we'll get to Paul Ryan and all the rest
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Jen you sell so you've
been wishing that those bags under your
eyes would just go away or your wife
she's been wishing that
well this is why Jen you sell is there
Jen you sell is a serum with plant stem
cell technology from shamon a my wife
uses it my mom uses it my mom steals the
materials from my wife in order to use
it okay it is just fantastic Susan from
New Jersey says I've been using Jen you
sell for a couple of months the
puffiness around my eyes is gone the
crows I the crow's feet the small lines
they've disappeared and they have not
come back again my wife uses it she
loves it my mom uses it she loves it my
sisters are getting it there's a reason
that Jen you sell is so popular and
that's because it works it with it's
instant effects you will see results
actually in the first 12 hours or your
money back
I guarantee it more importantly so do
the folks over at Shama nice so order
now get that Jen you sell college and
builder and deep firming serum two best
sellers also free you can look younger
you can look better call 866 320 904 800
663 2904 or visit Jen you Cellcom that's
G en you see al calm Jen you sell calm
866 329 oh four if you call right now
Express shipping is also free it's eight
oh six six six hundred eight hundred 663
2904 and again Jen you sell calm it's
Jenny so calm they've been advertising
with me since my days in Seattle and my
wife has continued to use their products
even since my days in Seattle has been
years now which is why my wife is young
and beautiful and smoking hot and also a
doctor so Jen you sell calm check it out
866 3 2904 try it for yourself they
really are great
ok so meanwhile these stormy Daniels
controversy continues now let's be real
about this the real reason that people
care about stormy Daniels it gives them
an excuse to Google stormy Daniels
lesbian activity on Google Images hey
let's be real about this mr. macdaniel's
were not a porn star nobody would care
about this because if we're going to
pretend that people are deeply worried
about the corruption of the Trump
administration there are a thousand
other stories that seem to go deeper on
the on the quote-unquote corruption
stuff than the stormy Daniels thing now
is it sort of a clean bust then Michael
Cohen paid $130,000 to shut her Yap when
it came to the election time yeah that's
bad
he's a campaign finance reform violation
not sure i mean john edwards paid nine
hundred thousand dollars to a woman to
keep her Yap shut after he fathered a
child with her right well he was married
to his cancer-ridden wife so
that is not yeah I'm not sure that that
this violates campaign finance law
what's funny is that Trump's approval
ratings continue to go up so yesterday
there was a big stock market bounce the
stock market yesterday jumped something
like six hundred and eighty points or
seven hundred points who's the third
biggest stock market gain in one day in
American in the history of the stock
market actually that is uh that's not
super surprising because there's such a
big stock market adjustment yesterday
the stock market is up again today so
you know it's it's up and down it's up
and down
I think part of that is because all of
the tariffs talked that's happening from
the Trump administration is starting to
soften just a little bit so the talk
before was that Trump was going to slap
these tariffs on products and leave them
there forever and now the talk is that
he's gonna slap the tariffs on long
enough to negotiate a better deal if the
latter is true and then all right I
guess that's okay
if the latter is not true then the stock
market will go back down again but in
any case people who are wondering why
Trump's approval rating is going up
beyond obviously the economics of all of
this one of the reasons that the the
approval ratings are going up is because
when you talk about a rich dude
stripping pornstars most people are like
well yep remember Donald Trump was
elected after building an entire
apartment decorated by Saddam Hussein's
decorator Donald Trump is not exactly
genteel about his wealth
hey it's funny when growing up my
grandparents my mom's parents were
relatively wealthy I wouldn't say that
they were like hugely enormously
successful but they owned their own home
they had their own business but one of
the things that I always appreciate
about my grandparents they never showed
off their wealth they always drove a
normal car they were not people who were
garish in their in their in their
spendthrift ways there are a lot of
folks who get rich and then they decide
that they're going to demonstrate to the
entire world just how wealthy they are
but the best people are the people who
you meet you don't know that they're
wealthy well Donald Trump is not one of
those people right Doug got famous for
being the really gauche guy on
lifestyles on the rich and famous that
was essentially his profile for a very
long time and there are a lot of folks
in the United States who want to be
Donald Trump it should be frank about
this there's an aspirational side to
Donald Trump that appeals to the worst
of our sensibilities where people who
are poor look at Donald trum they think
if I were rich you know many porn stars
I would know a lot man
I would really go for it okay so Donald
Trump stopping a porn start not a shock
again I'm not sure why we're supposed to
be surprised Melania Trump posed naked
with other women during the time that
Trump
dating her and went on Howard Stern and
talked too openly about their sex life
together like Milania now is is pretty
classy but back in the day when Trump
met her not so much I mean I believe he
was still married to wife number two
when he started going going with Melania
and when he was dating wife number two
he was still married wife number one in
fact there's a famous story I'm not sure
whether it's apocryphal or not I'm
fairly certain it is not but the story
is supposedly that when Donald Trump was
married to Ivana right who was involve
the Donald Trump was dating wife number
two right to his marlowe mates and Marla
mates was at the same resort where
Donald was keeping one wife Fran says
he's keeping wife number one on one
floor and he was keeping his mistress on
another floor and Ivana discovered that
Trump was in fact schtooping soon-to-be
wife number two on a different floor of
the hotel she found out about it while
he was on the ski slopes and she went up
to the top of the ski slopes with him he
tried to ski away from her and she was
yelling at him the entire way down the
hill while skiing backwards because it
vaana's actually heard expert skier so
again the the weird idea that Donald
Trump is some sort of prophetic godlike
wonderful Christian figure on sexual
morality is absurd in fact one of the
reasons he's popular is because Donald
Trump is the guy who unapologetically
stops porn stars so when they're when
he's in the news for stopping porn stars
and most guys are googling to figure out
how stormy Daniels looks naked he's not
gonna lose approval ratings from dudes
on that score and most women are gonna
look at stormy Daniels and go like are
we supposed to believe she's a victim
his moment about sex for money likely
this is her entire career is to have sex
for money on camera and she herself has
said she's not a victim she herself has
said that she is not a me-too person
that she fully consented to sex with
Trump and so we're thinking to ourselves
a lot of Americans are thing to
ourselves I'm not sure what the big deal
is here now again is it immoral yes it's
not all trumpet immoral that with women
yes should he be paying off women to
keep silent no is any of this surprising
no none of the surprised and none of
this is surprising the only thing that
is mildly surprising is the White House
keeps denying the underlying claim so
here's the White House yesterday being
asked about stormy Daniels and is Raj
Shah from the briefing room being asked
about stormy Daniels and and not coming
up with a fantastic answer
did you speak categorically that the
president
his campaign and the Trump Organization
did not violate federal law specifically
election laws regarding that payment
well I can speak for only the White
House and I can say categorically
obviously White House didn't engage in
any any wrongdoing the campaign or mr.
Cohen
yeah the campaign or mr. Cohen can
address anything with respect to their
actions with respect to that interview I
will say the president strongly clearly
and has consistently denied these
underlying claims and the only person
who's been inconsistent is the one
making the claims well I mean to be fair
do you believe that store McDaniels have
sex with Trump because I do like the
some of the inconsistency from stormy
Daniels is fully driven by her career
right she took the money when she felt
like that was the money she could get to
shut up and then she decided to speak up
when she feels like there's more money
in it to speak up store McDaniels is no
heroine here story is stormy Daniels is
a woman who had an affair with a married
man fully knowing that he was married
and did so for career reasons and then
she went quiet when it was time for her
to get paid by the Trump campaign
basically by by Michael Cohen and then
she decided to not shut up anymore when
it became obvious that she could make a
lot more money by not shutting up
anymore so stormy Daniels is not a
victim here that doesn't mean that Trump
is a saint we have this tendency in
American politics to say that there
can't be two villains in the same story
that if stormy Daniels is terrible than
Trump is wonderful and if Trump is
terrible than stormy Daniels is
wonderful
how about they're both scuzz okay just
in terms of personal morality and sexual
morality they are both just gross and
stormy Daniels his lawyer is showing
that on a pretty regular basis or me
Daniels is doing like stripping tours
now okay like right now in the middle of
this she's going around you know
basically making the pitch you can see
what Donald Trump saw well gentlemen
again Google is available you don't have
to pay stormy Daniels your money to see
what Donald Trump saw she's widely
available on the Internet in any case
storming Daniel's his lawyer was was
teasing the idea that maybe there's
pictures of Donald Trump naked which
would just be the worst of all possible
scenarios right I mean no one wants to
see that storming Daniels has said she
didn't want to see that at least or
McDaniels thought she had a shot on
Celebrity Apprentice we have to see two
pictures of Donald Trump in the nude
oh it's just gonna be so terrible just
now I don't actually believe by the way
as stormy Daniels has pictures of Trump
in the nude I think that is very very
unlikely this happened in 2006 camera
phones in 2006 we're garbage
you still had flip phones in 2006 okay
can only hope the pixelation was really
bad at that point but if it's true oh no
just no no no no just no he's been a
polygraph expert for three decades
no galvanic skin response no no blood
pressure the questions were all wrong
dude and you know the person who
administered this life I have no idea
you don't know I looked at a picture
thanks by the way thank you
for supplying that picture that last one
thank you she's not the last
oh yeah where is it buckle up you'll
need a big one but oh yeah okay so here
he says that maybe we have pictures
maybe we have pictures okay so we'll
find out whether he is bluffing or not
and then you had some other things to
say but to hear all of the other things
that stormy Daniels is lawyer is saying
about the star of The Witches of breast
wick that is an actual movie that stormy
Daniels is in you'll have to go over to
Daley where come and subscribe so for
$9.99 a month you get a subscription to
daily we're calm when you do that you
got the rest of this show live the rest
of Noel's show live the rest of Clavin
show live you got all of those various
glories plus you get to be part of our
mailbag get to ask live questions and
when you get the annual subscription for
$99 a year you get this the very finest
in all beverage vessels leftist here's
hot or cold tumblr it is just
magnificent can you get all that with
the annual subscription plus I will make
it appeal to you okay the fact is that
one of the things that helps our company
run is your subscription dollars and if
you can subscribe you are helping out
our come and get a lot of emails from
folks asking how they can help out with
our mission of helping to inform more
people keep people up on the news
promote conservative values subscribe
honestly it's a really good way to help
support us and ensure that all of the
otherwise unemployable waves that
populate our office still get to eat at
night and don't huddle in the cold
hungry under the overpasses in Los
Angeles so you can help make that happen
consider it an act of charity go over to
Daley we're calm right now and subscribe
or just want to listen later go over to
iTunes go over to SoundCloud go over to
YouTube please subscribe please leave us
a review
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
so that wasn't the only tease about
material that apparently stormy Daniels
still has on Trump one of the stormy
Daniels his friends her name is Alana
Evans she says she still has the dress
from the night that stormy Daniels
and Donald Trump got it on do you know
are you aware that she has any such
evidence and she spoken to you about it
or shown you anything along those lines
I am unaware about text messages or
pictures or any type of evidence she
might have that would fit on a disk all
I know is that stormy still has the
dress that she wore from that night
mm-hmm
and she kept that for what reason may be
keepsake maybe it's because it's actual
proof I can only speculate the things
that may be on that dress especially if
it's never been washed understood we'll
leave that there
yi not again are we doomed to live 1998
over and over again in perpetuity hi
guys this is one of the reasons why you
should not put that there without that
thing on it I mean like come on okay
also I do love this story this story is
from the Washington Post President Trump
has privately sold several people that
adult film star storming Daniels's
allegation but fair with him are a hoax
and that Daniels isn't the type of woman
he finds attractive what is that that
really is the strongest case that he
really is saying that stormy Daniels is
not the kind of woman that he finds
attractive okay I am currently looking
up a picture of Marla maples Marla
maples a dead ringer for the second your
Marla maples looks a lot like that woman
and if you look up a picture of Ivana
Trump when Ivana Trump was young if on a
Trump looked guess like whom Ivana Trump
looked she was a blonde buxom young
woman guess who she looked like stormy
Daniels Donald Trump has a type okay
Melania actually is less of his type
then stormy Daniels is but just what
come on just come on again none of this
is believable but none of its gonna hurt
Trump in in any real sense anyway
because as I say it's all baked into the
cake I don't think anything here is
gonna change now the only thing that
could change is if somehow stormy
Daniels comes up with these sort of evil
deep
threatener in 2011 so one of the
allegations stormy Daniels made during
that interview on CBS on 60 minutes was
that in 2011 she was ready to tell all
to In Touch magazine which shows you how
hot Trump was in 2011 the only people
who would pay for this story were in
touch for 15 grand and then she was
approached by someone some dark
mysterious figure who came to her in a
parking lot and said stormy your child
may grow up without a mother if you ever
tell the story about how Trump stepped
you now is it possible that happened
sure it's possible that happened maybe
we'll find out that was Michael Conant I
have my serious doubts that any of this
is true but storming Daniels's lawyer is
going after Michael Cohen where all of
this is just Jerry Springer material and
that's how most people in America are
treating it at this point because
honestly the only reason anybody's
watching this is because storming an old
support and start again for the 30th
time let's talk about Michael Cohen what
kind of man this is this is the kind of
guy who claimed in connection with that
story that there's no such thing as
spousal rape this is a legal genius
right right completely false the guy
doesn't even know the law he's a thug
your friend okay I love that Anderson
Cooper who's supposed to be the guy
keeping a lid on this he's just sitting
back and letting it happen to me it's
your one second away from Jerry Jerry
that's that's the next thing that
happens is that a vendetta this this
lawyer is gonna like pick up a chair and
clock this guy thug Thug that's a
million dollars a million a thug Thug
come on come on we're supposed to take
the scandal seriously I'm sorry I'm
having a tough time taking the scandal
seriously when the only reason everyone
is in it is for the Peorians appeal
that's really the only reason now is
Michael Kohn an idiot yes of course
Michael Kong's an idiot Michael Khan's
adult Michael holds a fool like I don't
know why this is a shock to anyone
Michael Kohn is a guy who said that
spousal rape is not a thing okay which
is idiotic Michael Kohn is the guy who
you recall from the last election cycle
he's on CNN and in the middle of the
election cycle when Trump was losing by
like ten points he was asked on CNN by a
Briana Keller why what was his opinion
on the polls and Michael Cohen said what
polls you remember this clip it went in
went viral at the time okay so is this
is any of this shot no but this
not coming off as something that's
threatening to the office of the
presidency you know the the famous quote
is that history doesn't doesn't repeat
itself but it does rhyme or that history
repeats itself the first time as as
tragedy the the first time is comedy the
second time is tragedy well I think in
this case it's the reverse the first
time was the tragedy and now we get to
watch the comedy because this is
uproariously funny stuff if you cannot
appreciate the fact that America's
culture has gone down in a flaming ball
of crap and we're all just watching from
the sidelines as it happens and talking
about stormy freakin Daniels Stephanie
Clifford and Donald J Trump the
President of the United States every so
often you just have to look around and
realize that we're actually living
inside a Salvador Dali painting yeah
this is one of those moments where you
realize that the Salvador Dali painting
has come to life the clocks are melting
off the side of the wall and and all of
the dimensions have been screwed around
with among other things so it's the
Trump by the way has been completely
silent about the stormy the annuals
thing which is probably the best
indicator that a lot of it is true but
there's no reason for him to talk about
it he should keep silent there's nothing
in it for Trump to talk openly about all
this stuff because again anything he
says is just gonna be more more fodder
for the fire but I will say the media's
attempts to turn stormy Daniels into
some sort of terrible victim case and
and some sort of you know heroine
speaking her truth okay this is a woman
who's on the make Trump was on the make
they're both gross there's a reason they
had sex with each other even though she
was not attracted to him and even though
he was married at the time because both
of them are just yucky humans okay this
is not a complicated story yucky humans
tend to be yucky and those yucky humans
continue to be yucky for years now none
of this is to say the Trump is a bad
president none of this is to say that
Trump is not doing things that I like in
the office of the presidency but I think
that we ought to acknowledge realities
about human character and the realities
of the characters involved in this ain't
nothing good happening here these are
not people you want your kids living up
to okay so meanwhile the only good news
for the Republicans is the Democrats the
Democrats continue to struggle with the
fact that their party is split in
serious measure between radicals and and
non radicals right between radicals and
people who are who are trying to move to
the moderate middle on the moderate
middle side people like Claire McCaskill
so Claire McCaskill's of course the
senator from Missouri her seat is in
serious trouble in Missouri quite
possible Missouri which has moved hard
red goes against Claire McCaskill and
McCaskill is trying to disown sort of
the radicalism of her own party
by throwing Hillary Clinton under the
bus this has been an additional move by
a lot of folks on the left recently so I
won the places that are optimistic
diverse dynamic and moving forward were
these comments from Hillary Clinton
helpful to you no probably not you know
I understand the point she was trying to
make but it felt like she was
criticizing Missouri voters and I would
draw I mean talking about drawing a line
I would draw a line there I have great
respect for Missouri voters so for those
of us that are in states that Trump won
we would really appreciate if she would
be more careful and show respect to
every American voter and not just the
ones who voted for her okay this is what
the Democrats have to do they have to
disown Hillary Clinton and they do have
to move to the middle this is one of the
things that we saw in that pa-18 race or
Connor Lam one he basically ran as a
moderate Democrat and he won if
Democrats run hard to the left they're
gonna be in some trouble but here's the
problem when it comes to the
presidential candidates they want the
people who are hardest to the left so
Mara so mitch landrieu is the new mayor
of New Orleans and he is seen as a
possible successor to Hillary Clinton as
the nominee in 2020 for no reason that I
can discern here is Mitch Landrieu
talking about American values okay this
is not gonna be a winning pitch and it
was fought for the cause of preserving
slavery it's hard to have a racial
reconciliation conversation unless we
could just clearly articulate that
particular truth and of course now that
we see in the moment that we're in that
when we're dealing with other issues
whether it's immigrants whether it's
transgender whoever it is that we have a
closed society we're turning away from
each other rather than towards each
other and when you begin to judge people
based on race creed call a sexual
orientation a country of origin that's
antithetical to what American values are
this entire country is built on the idea
that we treat people based on what they
do not who they are okay that's all true
except for the part about where he says
that we don't judge people based on
immigration status or transgender
behavior or any of the other stuff so
one of the things Democrats have had a
tendency to do and this is where you get
into identity politics is they have
identified behavior as identity right
your behavior is now your identity well
if that's the case then everyone is
discriminatory all of the time because
we all discriminate on the basis of
behavior people who you like juice
things that you like people you don't
like do certain things you don't like if
the idea is that if they do things you
don't like you're not allowed to condemn
them because that is their identity then
we have essentially put an end to any
sort of real-life judgment you can't
judge anyone because they're doing
things and the things they do make them
who they are
in reality we are supposed to separate
the actions that people take from who
they are in terms of immutable
characteristics so if you're a black
person who's a wonderful person you're a
wonderful person right the wonderful
person part is that is the part that
trumps any racial category right whether
you're black white or green if you are
but according to the left if you're a
black person a bad person the black
person's status overrides the bad person
status because black / bi people been
victimized by American society and we
cannot criticize you on because of your
particular race now the left is also
saying that if you are for example a man
who acts as a a woman right this is not
in fact an aspect of behavior this is an
immutable identity characteristic that
if you are a man who puts on a dress
this is somehow not behavior this is
identity and once you start identifying
behavior with identity then you can't
make laws on anything because everything
we do is behavior and every law that
discriminates against behavior
discriminates against someone's identity
by that very definition and literally
anything you do is now tied to your
identity so if you say that my
kleptomania is part of my identity
so we can't have laws against stealing
well then you've basically gotten rid of
all thievery laws in the United States
none of this is to say that there should
be laws against transgender identity a
transgender identification or
cross-dressing or there should be laws
against against you know any other form
of behavior that doesn't hurt anyone
else
but to be clear in our own minds
discrimination against identity is not
the same as discrimination against
behavior and conflating the two merely
confuses things conflating the two is
the end of law it's the end of
discrimination in a good sense and it's
the end of a civil society at large
because we can't make judgments about
anything if we can't make judgments
about anything we can't live in a
society together that isn't enough in
and of itself a judgement it's a
judgment that you can't make judgments
and that's a problem because we all make
judgments about each other all the time
okay time for some things I like and
then some things I hate and we'll do a
very brief deconstruction of the culture
so things I like
today I have been reading Joseph's
solavei chicks lonely Madoff and we're
coming up on Passover I'll have some
thoughts on Passover a little bit later
in the week probably tomorrow during our
biblical segment but this book the
lonely man of faith by Joseph
soloveitchik grabbed Rav salivate check
also known as the robbed in the Orthodox
Jewish community was the founder of
yeshiva university he was the the guy
who founded the idea of Torah Mada the
believed that you had to learn secularly
and you also had to learn in terms of
Torah so this is one of the things that
distinguishes the modern orthodox
community from certain parts of the car
ad community for example in the Orthodox
community there are certain parts of the
Orthodox community to think that you
should only engage with the Tories you
only engage inside the Jewish community
the modern orthodox community suggests
that you should read widely and you
should learn from a lot of people not
just from the Torah
although the Torah is the sacrosanct and
highest source of morality so solavei
check this book is accessible to
everybody and it's about the nature of
human beings and how we are essentially
dual right on the one hand we are the
achievers who seek to strike out and
forge your new paths as individuals on
the other hand we are communal people
who need a communal identity and an
identity in relation to the cosmos we're
not just brave warriors striking out
into chaos
we are also people who require a safe
safe harbor of religion and a
relationship with the transcendental
that allows us to feel worthwhile book
is a little bit of a hard read but it's
it's a well worth it read Joseph's
elevate check perhaps elevate check that
the lonely man of faith checked that out
just in time for Easter or Passover it's
equally applicable actually to both it's
quite clear okay other things let's see
other things that I like well the US did
expel 60 Russian diplomats so over the
weekend the Trump administration
announced that they were expelling 60
Russian diplomats after the Russians
poisoned a guy in Salus Barre England
can they poisoned a former spy sergey
skripnikov berry England and the United
States has expelled 60 Russian diplomats
from our country okay that of course is
is a worthwhile thing to do and it also
gives the lie to the idea that Trump is
not hard on Russia he says according to
the according to CNN this is the most
forceful action Trump has taken against
Russia today well I mean we also have
put on some pretty severe sanctions and
armed the Ukrainian rebel the Ukrainian
government against Russian backed forces
so again that gives the lie to the idea
that trumps
just been pro-russia all the way okay
time for a quick thing that I hate so
the thing that I hate today it's this
really really awful story there's an 85
year old woman who was murdered in
France she was a Holocaust survivor and
she was murdered by anti-semites in
France it's just a horrifying horrifying
story of course the police are saying
the motive is anti-semitism they have
not actually released the identities of
the suspects details were sparse
judicial official would only say that
one of the suspects was born in 1989 one
of the the one woman's son said we're
really in shock I don't understand how
someone could kill a woman who has no
money and lives in a social housing
complex her son said that one of the
suspects was like a son to no land a
frequent visitor who had come to her
apartment the day of the fire and she
was one of an estimated 7,000 French
Jews rounded up in 1942 and held at the
now demolished velde cycling track most
of those held were later deported to
Auschwitz she ended up marrying a fellow
Holocaust survivor settling down in
Paris and she lived there until her
death it's just horrifying and again
this was very much like the the murder
of Sarah Hawley me who was another
Orthodox Jewish issues a physicist in
kindergarten teacher and choose 66 and
she was thrown from a window last year
by anti-semitic Muslims living in France
again we don't know the identity of
these particular people but the rise in
anti-semitism across Europe is the
absolutely frightening and Jews should
leave okay they really should yeah it's
it's it's a sad thing to say but I think
the time for Jews to be able to live
safely in Europe is once again over
which demonstrates that they never again
sloganeering from the folks in Europe
was a bunch of crap they've allowed a
bunch of folks to move in who are fully
happy murdering Jews and it's it's
despicable okay a quick deconstruction
of the culture so today when we honor
cardi B so we've already done modak
yellow in which I tried to read through
her glorious Robert Frost like lyrics
but she actually did something that I
loved okay she paid taxes and then when
she paid taxes she realized hey wait a
second taxes suck
Sarah's cardi B in the most eloquent rip
on white acts is our garbage in modern
American history I mean this is better
than anything since Ronald Reagan hears
cardi B explaining that the government
should not be taking our money okay so
you know that government is taking 40%
of my
and Uncle Sam I want to know what you're
doing with my skin tax money because you
know what I'm saying like but you donate
like when you donate to a kid from a
foreign country they give you updates of
what they do much of the nation I want
to know what to do with my tax money
because I'm from New York and the
streets is always dirty we was voted the
dirtiest city in America what is y'all
doing this to rats on the trains I know
you're not spending it not prison
because y'all be giving there's like two
underwears one jumps ooh for like five
months so what is y'all doing with my
key money
what is you're doing with my money I
want to know I want receipts I want
everything I want to know what's doing
with my money
what is that doing with my money uncle
Sonny yes cardi B yes cardi B 2024
indeed yes that correct this is the main
question
now cardi B will go out and vote
Democrat I'm sure like all of her other
friends in Hollywood because she's been
told that that's what she has to do but
cardi B let it be known you have worked
hard for your money you've worked at
girl with an E and that means that you
ought to be protective of your cash
because the mo government is wasting
your money enormous quantities of it on
things like Social Security and Medicare
that you're not gonna need cuz you're
super rich okay there's no reason why
the government should be taking that
much of your money and you're right New
York is a steaming heap okay because
Bill de Blasio's a garbage mayor and
because they've done a terrible job
keeping the upkeep in that city decent
so you know like I'm gonna thank God the
crime rates are still low but that's
only because of the aftermath of
Giuliani and Bloomberg in any case cardi
B join us join the revolution okay taxes
suck you know it I know it let's forge a
partnership here Shapiro cardi B we can
make this happen we can bridge all the
gaps you can bring America together
around Uncle Sam why are you taking our
m effing taxes where is my effing money
where the receipts I want them what the
f cardi B ladies and gentlemen okay
we'll be back here tomorrow with much
much more plus we'll have a little bit
of biblical analysis in the run-up to
Easter and Passover so
lots of good stuff happening we will see
you then I'm Ben Shapiro this is Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alec singhara audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018